i had lyme disease several years ago i  got a diagnosis and i had a tempur-pedic  bed  and i didn't know any better at the time  and i was laying on it every night and i  was getting severe headaches and i was  lucky enough to have a doctor that was a  functional medicine doctor that said oh  my gosh you've got to get rid of that  bed today and it's interesting i got rid  of it within a week all of those  headaches left and it was day after day  and i'm not prone to migraines so it was  an interesting little experiment  so when we talk about this stuff people  need to understand first of all it can  be very overwhelming what we're talking  about here though are  cleaning products you use in your home  furniture you buy  detergents that you use makeup ladies  guys makeup hair spray  all of this stuff accumulates toxins in  the body